as you know when people know I'm coming
they'll tend to be on their best Bloody
Behavior so I'm going undercover
[Music]
Deputy Connor reporting for Duty
Oscar good to see you still yeah nice to
see you thank you so much side passed as
an officer yes join the drive no I'll
drive [__]
let's go
[Music]
so this restaurant had a great
reputation oh yeah is it on your list
now or have you crossed that off crossed
it up
let's hope it looks better on the inside
than the outside
at The Trolley Stop Cafe sheriff's
deputies eat at a discount but as I look
around at the mismatched tables and
filthy Decor I would hope that discount
means free you can tell that there's no
manager present how you guys doing hi my
name is Nikita I'll be your server y'all
ready already yeah I'm ready
we're ordering Classic Diner dishes I'm
gonna get a seafood omelette that any
New Orleans restaurant should consider a
Big Easy can I add a pecan yeah I'm
gonna get the fried chicken sandwich the
natural cheese it's less cowboy
[Music]
thank you
so we've been here 20 minutes now okay
the owner is nowhere to be seen
will do me a favor um
yeah I don't know yeah I'll keep the
food warm all right yeah and don't get
caught speeding
[Music]
Seafood Hamlet cheese
thank you and nachos
can you smell that it smells horrible
that has a smell
[Music]
that cheese is sour oh boy thank you my
oysters that's the oyster there
[Music]
so that way
that's not good
guys this is some of the most disgusting
food I've ever seen uh please don't eat
anything else okay yes I got this out
I'll be back in a minute okay
thank you
ah cheese on the nachos Jesus Christ
[Music]
let's get the puck out of here
my new friends and I are posing as fans
of the local hockey team the Lehigh
Valley Phantoms it's a great area around
here isn't it yeah yeah it's a nice area
right here
[Music]
well there it is okay guys let's go all
right hungry hungry
you got a blackened scallop out Tommy
ice cream
how are you thank you four of us when
you walk into the shanty it pays homage
to his name a crude run down Shack did
you guys want to high top yes perfect
thank you The Deco was lacking any sort
of identity and it feels more like a
sports bar than an upscale Bistro that
would serve the local theater crowd and
many look at the size of this [__]
it's huge
are you guys ready to order it Gene a
few minutes I think we're good you guys
ready with a menu that lacks any clear
Direction you know what I think I'm just
gonna have the shrimp Florentine please
we're ordering a hotspotch of menu items
I have the black and filet medium rare
please hopefully this meal doesn't land
Us in The Penalty Box
I have to go for the Goon burger oh yep
never sold that before thank you very
much
they've never sold a doom Burger before
yeah I found that interesting
yeah yeah sorry come on Kennedy I need
that Mojo that's coming Joe it's [__]
coming all the rest of the food went
outside
[__] shush
the [__] dude she's in an open kitchen
and she is absolutely swearing ahead off
I can hear from here get off my [__]
ass
very sorry about that um it's just under
a lot of pressure customers don't want
to hear that
I got another blackened scallop on the
board
blackened scallops yes sir
black and scallops is this a joke they
look burnt
thank you
oh my God
mine doesn't even taste fresh they taste
Frozen Hello in that black and play
Tommy two minutes at least per two
minutes
we've been sat here for 45 minutes guys
it's still no entrance
[Music]
all right shrimp Florentine that's me
goon Burger wow
oh my burger is Stone Cold I just tried
that shrimp one
help yourself
don't eat too much of those shrimp
please they taste sour glad to hear
there's nothing fresh air nine percent
of what we're eating is frozen I'll be
back in a minute all right please don't
eat too much yep okay
[Music]
scallops when blackened the skulls were
cremated
[Music]
when people know I'm coming they all
tend to be on their best Bloody Behavior
so I'll be blending in to the crowd
officer manager Bob time for lunch
how are we hey Daniel right yeah Grant's
Grant welcome Rocco uh
yeah yeah same going on are we ready for
some lunch
I'm gonna drive right oh my Lord here we
go what side of the road to drive on
here left or right
wow
that sign looks terrible this place
looks like an abandoned strip club honey
thank you
[Music]
my name is Jen and I'm gonna be taking
care of you thank you
the decor is the terrible it's dull
dingy it looks like a funeral home
oh my God the French onion soup and an
Italian restaurant oh my God we're
ordering classic dishes you guys want a
calamari stop shrimp without any
self-respecting Italian restaurant
should have perfected chicken parmesan I
can't stand chicken parmesan out of a
million beautiful food items in the
world why would you order chicken
parmesan or the pistachio scrub linguine
cleavage all right your calamari should
be right up there thank you
because if they caught it frozen and it
sucks
all right here we go the calamari oh
sorry about the land thank you you're
welcome
it's old damn please don't eat too much
guys
25 minutes in still no entry I mean 10
minutes time we need to go back to work
shake a problem
is I get one breaded
[Music]
there's no energy there's no passion and
that starts from the top
all right here we go pistachio Squad
there you go you're welcome chicken
parmesan thanks so much and there you go
he's made we don't have the [__] for
four days
after back everybody how was breading's
on that shrimp a lot why is there so
much breading on there nature shrimp
they're all shrimps are old too oh my
God I stink
s canals Bells please don't eat too much
of that stuffing please please please
how are the clams I think they've turned
they're gone
dead will never ever cook dead shellfish
oh my gosh guys I've seen enough give me
two minutes thank you excuse me
oh my God
okay terrible food terrible service drab
decor and this owner he's given up is
clearly evidence